et vous tout ce qui est de là c'est un
bonheur de de vous accueillir
sachant que nous nous quittons guerre
puisqu'il y a
avec Matthieu d'Arnaud qui est Cora
porteur de la mission lancée par le
président l'archet nous avons longuement
discuté avec les départements c'est
notre collègue j'en ai 11 Dupont Régis
notre collègue qui était sénateur pardon
j'en ai 11 du pont qui était là donc
président Sauvadet je suis vraiment
heureuse de vous accueillir j'ai entendu
beaucoup d'intérêt
vos déclarations lors du congrès des
départements de France nous avons déjà
eu le bonheur de vous recevoir et
aujourd'hui l'idée c'est à la fois je
n'ose dire de prendre le pouls des
départements parce que il est important
que la délégation collectivité
nourrissent un dialogue
nous nous sommes déjà appelés à la tâche
avec ce groupe de travail économique
puisqu'il réunit tous les groupes du
Sénat qui a été lancé par Gérard Larcher
nous parlerons même finances donc moi je
sais que ce travail va être fait avec
vous le président Larcher l'a dit donc
pouvons-nous là au sein de la négation
parler aujourd'hui de vos attentes en
matière peut-être de réorganisation de
compétences sachant que pour nous il
n'est nullement question de repartir
dans un
chamboule-tout qui à un moment pose un
certain nombre de questions il faut une
stabilité mais surtout mettons-nous
d'accord sur cet objectif partagé entre
l'État et nous tous qui est l'efficacité
de l'action publique jusqu'au dernier
kilomètre à partir d'un principe simple
qui est celui de la subsidiarité
permettent à la collectivité la mieux
placée
et puis nous avons aussi un travail très
important que nous avons engagé avec le
Conseil d'État c'est peut dire de
l'importance du sujet de la gravité et
le Conseil national d'évaluation des
normes sur ce qu'on appelle la
simplification
alors c'est toujours le cauchemar et la
quête du Graal est en même temps on en a
parlé hier avec le président Larcher ça
nous renvoie la fabrique de la loi c'est
dire que nous nous soyons aussi
raisonnable voilà dans la fabrique de la
loi mais que sur tous les décrets
d'application ne viennent pas comme une
dérive de l'esprit du législateur je
n'ose pas parler d'usage parce que voilà
c'est comment à un moment le décret
d'application transforme et contrarie
contrarie l'esprit du législateur et que
la norme finit par nuire et empêcher
l'action publique voilà quelques sujets
ou quelques thèmes monsieur le Président
qui réjouissent toujours notre
délégation ou qui nous désespèrent parce
que je pense que l'éternité ne suffira
pas à régler le problème mais nous
sommes
sans avoir l'espoir d'avoir cette vie
nous ne renonçons pas merci monsieur le
président
d'abord je suis venu surtout pour
répondre aux questions et éventuellement
que vous pourriez nous nous poser
simplement un mot de contexte
d'abord on est dans un contexte vous le
savez tous puisque vous êtes sur le
terrain et au contact des élus locaux
dans un contexte très lourd
très lourd après on a traversé déjà deux
années de pandémie et aujourd'hui
on voit la montée des précarités coût de
l'énergie
évidemment l'inflation et donc on voit
que ça grimpe l'échelle des classes
moyennes tout simplement et les graves
difficultés je crois qu'on ne dit pas
assez que cette crise énergétique cette
crise donc ce gène aussi pour nos pour
nos patriotes et elle frappe surtout et
avant tout le monde rural parce qu'il y
a pas d'alternative à la voiture dans le
monde rural je crois que aussi qu'il
faut le dire et donc c'est un impact
encore bien plus important sur le monde
rural lui-même et on le constate tous
les jours au travers des divers
différents plans de solidarité qu'on est
à mettre en place puisqu'on est en
première ligne les départements de
France aux côtés de l'État pour faire
face à cette vague des des difficultés
au quotidien nos familles il y en a dû
prendre des initiatives aussi pour
accompagner les personnes qui qui
n'avaient plus les moyens de mettre de
l'essence ou du gazole dans leur voiture
pour aller travailler tout simplement
moi je mets en place un dispositif
j'étais extrêmement surpris de voir
qu'il y avait 1600 foyers qui après
analyse de leur situation personnelle on
a même fait former des des agents chez
nous en lien avec la Banque de France
qui ont évidemment rôle particuliers en
matière de surendettement et on voit que
que les les situations cedendent bon
donc on est en première ligne c'est un
choc pour nos compatriotes c'est un choc
aussi pour nos collectivités
nous coups surcons on a eu une série
d'annonces d'ailleurs pour lesquelles on
a on avait été appelé pour certaines
d'entre elles à discuter on a eu coup
sur couplage dans 43 vous savez pour les
aides à domicile la revalorisation là
encore on nous a rajouté un euro
supplémentaire d'ailleurs sans même nous
avoir associés à la prise de décision on
est passé à 23 à 23 euros en tout cas on
va passer à 23 euros dès que le décret
sera paru sur l'aide à domicile bon là
on n'est pas été informé évidemment c'en
était mieux franchement
quand on fait de la GO construction il
faut il faut que ce soit co-construit
sinon ça va sinon c'est une décision qui
s'impose à nous bon on a obtenu quand
même la compensation de cette euro
supplémentaire on a eu ensuite là aussi
sans discussion la revalorisation du RSA
le point d'indice là aussi sont sans
discussion avec nous on a et puis
l'extension du Ségur pour lequel nous
avons été associés et qui était
extrêmement compliqué parce que ce Ségur
et bien évidemment qui était décidé par
le gouvernement à lui seul immédiatement
a suscité un sentiment d'incompréhension
et d'injustice de la part de tous ceux
qui participaient en première ligne dans
le médico-social par exemple et qui
n'était pas
reconnu avec une un accompagnement cinq
particulier pour avoir été en première
ligne sur les sur les sur les
problématiques de sur les problématiques
de pandémie et donc évidemment ça
suscité une colère
et donc on a passé notre temps à suivre
les oubliés du Ségur jusqu'à un moment
donné il fallait quand même s'arrêter
donc on a eu ces discussions avec
Monsieur Castex bon avec un partage des
des
enjeux financiers mais en tout cas en
plus maintenant il y a l'inflation
l'énergie inflation dans nos collèges
évidemment comme toutes les
collectivités vous le savez mieux qui
compte et puis on a l'énergie dans mon
seul département le coût de l'énergie
est passé de 4,5 millions et demi à 11
millions d'euros enfin on mesure le choc
alors quand j'entends parfois dire
aujourd'hui encore et je l'ai dit auprès
du président de la Cour des comptes que
les départements se portent bien en
motif qui a eu des droits de mutations
élevés c'est vrai que les droits de
mutation ont été élevées mais je ne sais
pas ce qui serait passé si les droits de
mutation n'avaient pas été à cette
hauteur et encore ils ont été répartis
évidemment inégalement et donc il y a
des départements qui aujourd'hui sont en
très très grandes difficultés et je vous
le dis il y a des départements qui ne
peuvent plus faire se passe et qui ne
pourront pas équilibrer leur budget
alors inutile de vous dire que la je
reviens des Ardennes par exemple bon ils
étaient les héritiers de gros
investissements notamment routier
autoroutier pour lesquels ils avaient
été appelés à participer par l'état
d'une charge qui subsiste donc ils ont
des droits de mutation qui en volume
restent limité même s'ils ont cru et
donc évidemment qu'ils se retrouvent en
grande difficulté alors je voudrais
insister aussi auprès de vous pour dire
que nous avons fait des efforts
considérables alors on nous parle de la
différence qu'il y a entre le la
perception des droits de mutation
certains commencent même à les
revendiquer à dire il n'y a pas de
légitimité à ce qui est des droits de
mutation pour les départements moi je
vous invite à y réfléchir sérieusement
parce que les droits de mutation c'est
c'est un transfert de propriété de
logement etc d'activité qui est au cœur
de l'action autour du logement et même
du logement qui fait des routes dans
dans notre pays des routes gratuites
pour les usagers je le rappelle et on
est attaché cette gratuité qui fait les
routes qui les finance c'est bien les
départements donc il fait
l'environnement du logement qui refait
quai de les communes à refaire les
places etc on est à côté de logement
donc pour tous ceux qui s'interrogent
sur la légitimité et pour nous je vous
le dis il y aura vraiment une idée de
rouge à l'égard du gouvernement c'est
son on remet en cause les droits de
mutation dans nos départements donc nous
avons fait une péricquation on est le
seul niveau de collectivité à avoir fait
un niveau de péréquation d'ailleurs il
faut le protéger parce que je reprends
l'exemple des Ardennes ils ont 20
millions mais ils ont touché une
péréquation j'ai plus dehors de
plusieurs millions voire dizaines ça
chiffre une dizaine de millions donc
évidemment que cette péréquation elle
est elle est là maintenant la vraie
question qui est posée à l'état
et parfois qui nous dit que nous avons
des politiques différenciées parfois que
nous ne remplissons pas tous la mission
comme il l'entendrait sur le terrain la
première des inégalités c'est pas celle
dont la façon dont nous abordons nous
les compétences dont nous avons la
charge la première des inégalités c'est
que l'État ne nous donne pas les moyens
par une
compagnement vertical ne nous donne pas
les moyens de faire face aux missions
qu'il nous confie aujourd'hui je peux
vous le dire dans les allocations
individuelles de solidarité nous les
faisons nous départements à plus de 50%
désormais 54% pour être précis que ce
soit la location pour le handicapés que
ce soit le RSA d'ailleurs on aurait eu
tout un débat sur le RSA ou la notion du
disait on augmente mais parce que vous
aurez moins de bénéficiaires ça vous
coûte moins cher je suis désolé moi j'ai
moins de bénéficiaires je fais tout pour
qu'il y ait moins de bénéficiaires mais
la hausse qu'on m'a imposée c'est 2
millions et demi d'euros de plus par pas
par an en année pleine donc vous voyez
que je veux dire on nous annonce une
hausse en nous prétendant que la hausse
c'est une baisse enfin faut être sérieux
enfin c'est pas une bonne façon
d'aborder les choses on a des défis
considérables vieillissement de la
population le maintien à domicile la
question de la violence aussi c'est les
jeunes la question de la psychiatrie
chez les jeunes et on sent un peu seul
vous savez quand vous n'avez pas de
réponse psychiatrique dans un
département qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
jeunes les jeunes violents dans la rue
on a déjà bien des difficultés à les
canaliser et ça ça relève de la Justice
de la police ou de la gendarmerie mais
et puis de l'accompagnement sociétal
évidemment est familiale mais on a aussi
tous les jeunes qui nous sont confiés
qui sont en situation de graves fracture
et pour lesquelles on a juste une qu'on
a 20 à 30% de jeunes qui relèvent
aujourd'hui de soins psychiques et
psychiatriques alors quand on en parle
au gouvernement on va dire bah oui il
faut qu'on forme des des psychologues
des psychiatres on sent bien seul on a
des cas de violences incroyables dans
nos dans nos établissements qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on nous emmène au CHU pour
une situation d'urgence ils sont gardés
trois quatre heures on vous les redonne
ils sont soi-disant stabilisés face aux
urgence ils reprennent une crise on les
ramène encore à l'hôpital dans du
attendez on les a déjà vu on s'est plus
on sait plus faire on va dans les
hôpitaux spécialisés il y a peu de lit
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait on vous les
renvoie
et on est dans un problème après ça de
personnes et de d'agent d'association
qui se mettent même en déport parce que
ils estiment qu'ils sont eux-mêmes en
danger et qui ne sont plus en situation
de garantir la sécurité dans les
établissements dont ils ont et vis-à-vis
des enfants dont ils ont la charge voilà
situation donc il faut que l'état donne
les moyens des objectifs qu'ils fixent
et ce et lui-même de se défaussent pas
sur les responsabilités qui sont les
siennes et le soin médical notamment
psychique et psychiatrique c'est c'est
c'est
évidemment c'est la relève de sa
responsabilité alors évidemment qu'on a
qui vous permettez juste une petite
interruption mais en lien avec ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure sur la
situation extrêmement difficile de
certains départements ce dont je ne
doute pas vous les estimez à combien moi
je pense qu'il y a une quinzaine de
départements qui sont en situation très
vraiment compliquée d'ailleurs j'ai
demandé au gouvernement à ce que on
puisse regarder leur situation qui en a
un accompagnement parce que évidemment
il y a la question conjoncturelle et une
question structurelle mais aussi il y a
ceux qui ont un endettement pour lequel
l'État nous a appelé à participer oui
mais ça j'attends des précisions sur la
méthode m'a annoncé qu'on prendra en
compte la situation singulière des
départements qui sont mais je n'ai
absolument pas de actuellement de
réponse concrètes et là ils vont rentrer
dans les budgets il y a des départements
je vous dis celui des Ardennes par
exemple il est en il est en marge brut
et net négative c'est à dire il n'a pas
les moyens de faire face il attend des
visites en terme clair
avec les obligations bon alors dernière
chose donc à ça s'ajoute des défis bon
ça c'est la situation que nous
connaissons tous sur la difficulté de
faire face et donc évidemment quand vous
avez des charges qui augmentent dans mon
département je prends un exemple 500
millions d'euros de budget entre tout ça
mille bout à bout les augmentations
imposées les revalorisations salariales
le choc de la précarité
les allocations individuelles l'énergie
l'inflation c'est 30 millions d'euros
supplémentaires
très simple je tiens les budgets à votre
disposition 30 millions d'euros
supplémentaires
donc évidemment avec une marge une marge
brute puis nette qui était de l'ordre de
40 millions je m'inquiète surtout que
j'entendais le gouvernement nous dire il
y aura une baisse de mutation un choc
qui sera de l'ordre de 2 3 4 % je n'y
crois pas le choc sera beaucoup plus
lent mais violent on connaîtra pas de le
choc de 2008 2009 on a vu les droits de
mutation qui s'étendraient que c'était
effondré de 50% mais on aura une baisse
tendanciellement assez forte je crois
taux d'intérêt évidemment difficulté
accès au crédit vous connaissez la
question du taux d'usure etc qui est là
aussi avec une volonté de mettre un
frein évidemment par rapport à
l'inflation et ça le gouverneur de la
Banque de France surviendra pas
là-dessus donc difficulté d'accès au
crédit tension dans les budgets des
ménages et puis évidemment
la question du caractère anxiogène de la
situation qu'on vit qui ne vous engage
pas forcément à les faire des
acquisitions et puis les investisseurs
le FSG qui prend pu mettre en location
dans les dans les deux ans qui viennent
enfin on a quand même une série
d'indicateurs qui nous montre et
d'ailleurs on le ressent dès maintenant
on a un fléchissement des droits de
mutation donc une période de forte
tension sur la dépense pas de baisse des
droits de mutation qui va arriver moi je
l'estime dans mon département à 20%
en plus vous avez vous allez plus de
marge de manœuvre financières parce que
vous n'avez plus d'autonomie
il va il va donc la situation non
seulement n'est pas bonne mais je crains
une dégradation très forte vous savez
moi j'étais parlementaire j'ai été
membre d'un gouvernement je ne cherche
pas à faire du lobby quand on est face
une crise de tel ampleur dans un pays
tout le monde doit se mettre en
situation de responsabilité je vous dis
une situation mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs qui est une situation clinique
et moi je tiens mais mon budget des
budgets des départements votre
disposition cela dit en plus on a des
nouveaux défis défis de changement
climatique pour lequel paradoxalement
nous nous retrouvons là aussi en
première ligne nous sommes les premiers
financeurs des services départementaux
d'incendie de secours
vous imaginez le choc les feux de forêt
auparavant on avait nord sud le nord
descend dans le sud aujourd'hui vous
avez vu des feux de forêt dans le
Morbihan des feux de forêt dans le
sud-est des feux de forêts en Gironde
des mégafeux comme on a appelé des feux
de forêt dans l'Est de la France donc
évidemment la dimension zonale de
l'organisation reprend tout son sens et
donc il va falloir faire des
investissements pour prépositionner j'ai
envoyé une mission flash vous le savez
sur ces sujets bon qui a bien travaillé
avec Jean-Luc glaise évidemment et qui a
travaillé enfin Pascal Martin c'est le
sait
donc cette mission a de ses conclusions
on voit bien que là aussi on va être un
choc alors si on est dans une situation
paradoxale il faut qu'on mette les
choses à plat quand j'entends le
ministre de l'Intérieur nous dire les
départements ne donnent pas la taxe des
assurances ne reverse pas la part de
taxes des assurances qu'ils ont sur les
sur les sur les 10 mais franchement
c'est un gag c'est un gag qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire est-ce qu'on se souvient de
l'histoire de la constitution du
versement de la taxe on a voulu lui
faire tous les jeux il y avait d'abord
le remplacement de la vignette et une
partie des dotations puis après il y a
une partie effectivement dédiée alors
moi il veut que je remette exclusivement
toute la taxe très bien la part dédiée
pour les 10 dans mon département c'est 8
millions
actuellement l'an prochain je vais
mettre 21 millions
on verse pas la taxe
alors la vraie question c'est comment on
fait contribuer aussi les communes et
comment les tasses montrent solidaires
il y a eu le chef de l'État annoncé 150
millions d'euros pour l'investissement
il faut qu'on soit aidé sur
l'investissement puis il faut qu'on soit
aidé aussi sur le financement donc on a
demandé à fond d'investissement les 150
millions à l'échelle d'un pays
j'ai regardé bon c'est bien non
franchement c'est bien mais est-ce que
c'est à la hauteur du défi du changement
climatique et des feux de forêt qui
nécessitent des moyens je vous le dis
assurément non donc nous sommes en
première ligne sur ce sujet et en plus
le paradoxe c'est que nous sommes
devenus là aussi les premiers financeurs
on paye plus de la moitié de la charge
des 10 l'autre moitié se partageant avec
les communes mais quand vous avez des
communes qui sont importantes et des
métropoles vous avez un mécanisme de
plafonnement à l'inflation
bon donc ça veut dire que tout est fort
différentiel est supporté par le
Département voilà ce que ça signifie
donc changement des filles numériques
j'ai vu le débat sur l’ifère je suis
choqué parce qu'il s'est passé sur
l'hiver franchement l'Isère
photovoltaïque avoir des compétitions
qui suivent entre entre entre entre
niveau de collectivité je sais pas c'est
un niveau de collectivité d'ailleurs les
communautés de communes qu'on
éloffensive pour avoir la partie de
l'ifère de la portée de 50 à 30 est-ce
que est-ce que l'hiver à vocation est
supprimé pour les départements
franchement qui qui a dit qui a déployé
la fibre dans dans beaucoup de
départements français qu'il a déployé
qui a fait l'environnement donc la part
de réduction de l'ifère je trouve que
c'est scandaleux parce que c'est un
mauvais signal le Sénat c'est bien tenu
mais malheureusement la CMP ah non non
je vous fais compliment moi je je salue
la qualité de relation que nous avons de
travail avec le Sénat d'ailleurs si vous
si vous n'étiez pas là je crois que les
départements ne seraient pas là que la
France se porterait très mal encore plus
mal voilà ma conviction profonde donc
voilà on a donc le schéma on a donc le
défi de la transition numérique aussi à
faire qui va être maintenant qu'on aura
déployé la fibre et là aussi on est en
première ligne 30% de notre temps
d'agent aujourd'hui est consacré à aider
les familles en précarité ou en
difficulté par rapport à la au numérique
pour terminer
la vraie question qui est devant nous au
moment on parle de décentralisation et
je termine je vous promets la vraie
question qui est devant nous qu'est-ce
qu'on veut faire qu'est-ce qu'on veut
comme qu'est-ce qu'on veut pour la
France avec un de formidable mutation un
choc financier énergétique alimentaire
qu'est-ce qu'on veut on veut agir
efficacement pour les Français quel est
le bon niveau pour agir efficacement
pour les Français moi j'ai fait 103
propositions qui émanaient du terrain
j'ai demandé à tous les départements de
me dire comment on peut agir mieux
comment simplement on peut agir mieux
alors effectivement je partage votre
sentiment on a des débats nous aussi au
sein de départements de France selon les
situations il y en a qui sont restées
sur le schéma bloc de compétences
ressourcis afférentes je n'y crois plus
à cela parce que le bloc de compétences
aujourd'hui nous engageons toute une
vision à 360 degrés quand vous parlez de
l'enfance vous parlez évidemment d'une
compétence
responsabilité pénale du président de
département mais vous parlez de la
justice vous parlez de la qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de ces enfants qui qui
commettent des actes violents coups de
couteau etc quand on fait la justice ils
sont éducatif fermé les etc les médecins
psychiatrie vous avez une vision à 360
est-ce qu'on est armé pour avoir de
véritables chefs de fila vous avez vu la
difficulté qu'on a eu simplement dans
les gestion de collège pour faire passer
dans la 3DS le fait qu'on puisse avoir
un pouvoir d'injonction sur le
gestionnaires de collèges et ça finit
par quoi vous laver voté législateur et
ça se termine par un guide dans lequel
on a toutes les difficultés admettent en
place sur le terrain par un guide de
bonnes pratiques alors et simplement
pour dire au gestionnaire nous voulons
avoir plus de 50% d'achat d'alimentation
de produits de proximité dans vos
cantines avec l'argent qu'on met pour le
repas à côté des familles c'est
incroyable regardez sur les EHPAD on
nous dit vous contrôlez pas attendez
qu'est-ce que vous faites sur un
directeur ce quel pouvoir d'ajonction
sur un directeur on paye le prix de
journée en aucun pouvoir d'injonction
rien
aucun pouvoir pour le nommer et
souvenez-vous pendant la pandémie le
présent département n'arrivait même pas
à voir l'information du nombre de décès
à l'intérieur d'un établissement
est-ce qu'on peut fonctionner comme ça
dans le pays alors que nous sommes en
charge de l'accompagnement et du prix de
journée bon donc il faut être très
concret dans cette affaire puis quand je
vois les revendications faudra qu'on se
mette au clair le tourisme c'est une
compétence partagée est-ce qu'on a
besoin de schéma touristique régionaux
pour dire ce qu'on doit faire en matière
de touristique dans le département de la
Côte d'Or je viens de créer une marque
beaucoup de départements créent des
marques est-ce qu'on va avoir sur
l'échelon régional une nouvelle tutelle
dans lequel on va nous dire voilà ce
qu'il faut que vous fassiez c'est une
vraie question de fond j'aime les
régions
mais cela dit qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans
le sport compétences partagées c'est
nous qui sommes en première ligne pour
le sport pour tous sport handicap etc
qui est dans les associations sportives
songez qu'au niveau de l'Agence
nationale du sport on est même pas
membre du bureau
trouve ça normal
je l'ai dit à son président Philippe a
fait évoluer les choses
sinon paiera plus
vous avez également dans le dans le dans
le dans les schémas du sport ils sont
territoriaux maintenant territorisés à
l'échelle de la région donc les tasses
s'adresse à la région et ensuite c'est
la région qui fixe le périmètre et qui
nous dit maintenant en fait fait comme
on vous a dit les espaces naturels
sensibles c'est la même chose c'est ce
qu'on va régler vous avez vu les
problèmes de bassine etc on a un choc
climatique vous croyez qu'on va régler
ça depuis depuis Paris ou depuis
localement les régions sans proximité
tout ça avec la rentre dans un dialogue
constant avec la population est de bonne
échelon pour agir c'est c'est les
départements puis je terminerai par un
autre exemple regardez je suis
propriétaire au titre du département de
la colonne d'une ressource en eau qui
représente 30% de la consommation d'eau
de la métropole qui jeûne enfin
métropole entre guillemets dijonnaise
songer j'ai le droit de produire de
l'eau brute je n'ai pas le droit de
produire de l'eau potable de la produire
mais comment vous expliquer ça du coup
comme aucun syndicat n'a la taille pour
reprendre pour reprendre l'exploitation
et puis la distribution à proximité on
se retrouve avec une ressource d'eau que
nous ne pouvons pas mobiliser alors j'ai
entendu le président du Sénat je suis
content que ça évolue dire voilà
faudrait que ce soit une compétence
optionnelle après ton accord avec la
syndicat c'est un département veut
s'engager pour accompagner la profession
agricole pour faire des réserves
stratégiques et s'engager pour
accompagner les la coordination de la
production en tout cas de la production
d'eau à l'échelle d'un département
pourquoi on nous empêche de faire au nom
de quoi surtout que nous sommes à des
principaux financeurs de l'eau aux côtés
des agences de l'eau donc d'un coton
vient nous chercher en financement et on
nous donne pas les moyens de déterminer
en lien avec l'État et en lien avec nos
partenaires région Mr une politique
départementale c'est là c'est là où où
on rentre dans un univers
d'incompréhension totale donc on est à
la fois nationale
il y a une amélioration du dialogue avec
le gouvernement mais enfin il y a quand
même une techno structure qui reste
stable j'utilise la fonction publique je
vais à peu près comment ça fonctionne le
changement de ce point de vue et devant
nous toujours devant
sur les relations avec la techno
structure bon et puis on est confronté
avec un échelon régional qui aujourd'hui
n'a pas la capacité à faire sur le
terrain et qui donc décide du cadre
général sur lequel on intervient donc il
va falloir bouger ce cadre sans quoi
vous savez ce qui va se passer on va
rentrer dans un royaume on va avoir une
double à double effet et je termine à
suivre vraiment le premier effet c'est
les conséquences de l'absence
d'autonomie financière et donc
effectivement l'étranglement des
départements première victime ce sera
l'investissement
et l'investissement précisément qui est
un investissement
territorialisé c'est-à-dire en direction
du monde rural pour l'essentiel
et puis la deuxième la deuxième
conséquence de cette situation c'est
quand on trouvera dans l'inertie quand
le gouvernement nous dira fait nous ne
ferons pas quand ils lancera des appels
à projets nous irons plus c'est ce que
j'ai expliqué au gouvernement pour avoir
toutes les idées que vous voudrez vous
irez chercher les acteurs qui iront
engager parce que ils n'auront pas ni la
compétence
reconnue pour faire
si ce n'est par l'injonction oui c'est
la jonction c'est le déni de la
compétence évidemment et donc vous et
puis des régions qui qui se livreraient
au même exercice donc voilà c'est ce
cadre là qu'il faut réfléchir et prendre
pas par point c'est des empêchements
d'agir c'est ça sans quoi je vous assure
on aura on va rentrer dans une période
de grande turbulences territoriale on a
connu la crise des gilets jaunes
si la situation se poursuit sans qu'on
apporte des réponses concrètes au
département pour agir aux côtés des
côtes d'Orient comme aux côtés de tous
les départements français et bien je
peux vous dire qu'on ira vers des
mouvements
incontrôlés des violences
infra familiales ou des violences
périphériques on en connaît de plus en
plus dans tous les départements et je
crains fort une montée de ces violences
voilà je vous le dis en toute sincérité
puis je vous remercie vraiment
d'organiser régulièrement des rencontres
avec les acteurs de terrain que nous
sommes parce que mais je sais que vous
connaissez ces situations bien vous êtes
sénateurs et sénatrice mais en tout cas
ça vaut le coup qu'on croise notre
appréciation de la situation pour qu'on
essaye d'agir mieux au service de nos
compatriotes et dans toute réforme faut
qu'on se pose cette question est-ce que
le système comment on place il est
efficace est-ce qu'on s'en assure et moi
j'accepte qu'on vienne tester nos
capacités à faire qu'on vienne nous
évaluer mais qu'on nous laisse faire
agir
merci monsieur le Président pour ce
propos qui
je crois je suis même sur rejoint la
philosophie du du Sénat alors rapidement
vous passez la parole à mes à mes
collègues en écho à ce que vous disiez
moi je salue
l'effort unique de péréquation qui a été
fait par les départements à partir des
MTO voilà
si on applique le principe aide-toi et
le ciel t'aidera je pense que l'État
doit prendre en considération ce que
vous avez fait qui est assez unique
alors j'ai une question un peu générale
sur donc le transfert de compétences
et l'évaluation du coût du transfert ce
qui peut y avoir transfert dans un
dialogue à condition que on est le juste
prix si je puis dire et le juste prix
évoluent donc nous ce que nous avions
intégré dans les 50 propositions en
faveur des libertés locales que le
gouvernement
n'a pas souhaité retenir c'était une
sorte de clause de revoyure pour une
évaluation
du coût de la compétence transférée
allant même que entre le moment on a été
transféré le moment où on fait
l'évaluation il y a eu des imputations
de décision qui sont des décisions
nationales et que vous devez prendre en
compte et que vous alimentez avec votre
budget donc ça cette clause de de
revoyure pour l'évaluation voilà c'est
la première chose deuxième question
autour des 10 les 10 c'est un sujet vous
emportez la responsabilité moi quand
j'entends les communes dire que elle
aussi très impactée
par toutes leurs dépenses retrouvent à
financer un peu plus de 40% c'est un
sujet
que les départements soient amenés à
dire aux communes ben écoutez nous on va
augmenter votre contribution moi
j'entends mais j'ai pas d'opposer les
uns les autres mais le jeudi la sécurité
incendie c'est une compétence régalienne
donc ne faudrait-il pas que l'État même
s'il transfert l'opérationnalité et moi
je trouve que vous êtes extrêmement
opérationnel il garantit la sécurité
incendie comme aujourd'hui l'État assure
en tout cas l'essentiel de la sécurité
intérieure et que la police municipale a
un rôle complémentaire mais on ne
confond pas les choses
donc je pense que il faut en tout cas
quand on parle du financement
du côté du pense font rappeler à l'état
que c'est d'abord une compétence
régalienne et puis dernier point que mes
collègues aborderont aussi dans nos 50
propositions en faveur des libertés
locales donc nous avons souhaité
reconnaître la capacité des départements
agir
dans le médico-social je vais dire un
mot sur ce que vous avez dit sur les
gestionnaire de collège et de lycée on a
inventé en 2022 la possibilité d'une
convention
possibilité qui existe depuis 1984 date
du transfert des personnels et j'ai
demandé à l'époque à Jacqueline Goro
ministre éducation nationale faites moi
un état du nombre de conventions qui ont
été signés en train département et un
gestionnaire de lycée et ben personne ne
sait donc on réinvente un truc qui date
de 40 ans qui est une très mauvaise
invention donc nous nous poursuivons là
dessus et puis nous avions beaucoup
parlé de la médecine scolaire la
médecine scolaire est aujourd'hui
extrêmement indigente
et elle est inopérante puisque je le dis
beaucoup d'amitié et de reconnaissance
des personnels aujourd'hui les
infirmières scolaires et les médecins
scolaires sont plutôt des autos
entrepreneurs parce qu'ils doivent
intervenir en urgence partout et il
diagnostique mais ils n'ont pas les
solutions opératives donc sous réserve
naturellement
que les départements apprécieraient sous
réserve d'une évaluation du coût du
service exigé et du transfert de moyens
sachant qu'aujourd'hui je sais qu'il y a
pas le personnel à doc mais que
pensez-vous de cette idée on a beaucoup
défendu au Sénat de confier au
département le service de médecine
scolaire vous avez la PMI
nous nous proposons que le service de
médecine scolaire qui permet à aucun
enfant de passer sous les radars c'est
quand même un enjeu sérieux aille
jusqu'au lycée épidermie
c'est celui du handicap et des aesh
aujourd'hui l'État développe une
politique des colles inclusives
qui est parfois je pense un peu
illusoire dans la capacité à faire bref
là n'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui mais
que aujourd'hui vous avez des
départements via les MDPH qui font des
prescriptions l'éducation nationale qui
doit mettre en oeuvre mais qui n'a pas
les budgets voilà et puis vous avez le
temps méridien ou une commune de 200
habitants qui a occasionnellement un
enfant handicapé qui doit être
accueillir à la cantine doit trouver une
personne une heure et demie par jour un
faisable donc moi là enfin l'idée qui me
vient à l'esprit c'est est-ce qu'il est
possible de réfléchir au fait que cette
fonction qui est extrêmement importante
elle est liée au handicap et que les
départements pourraient conforter cette
fonction de la esa sécuriser proposer
des carrières à des personnels
quittent ensuite à mettre à disposition
à titre payant si je puis dire ou à
l'éducation nationale
collectivités du personnel j'en ai
terminé et vous êtes très sollicité
puisque
Thierry cosy que notre collègue a des
questions Didier Rambaud on va faire
cette première série Pascal Martin et
ses livres là merci monsieur le
président
oui merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président merci pour vous propose
que je voulais évoquer avec vous le
premier sur la décentralisation et
repartir des propos du président de la
République
Lord sa réception des mers à l'Elysée le
23 novembre dernier qui a affirmé sa
volonté de faire une vraie
décentralisation
chez dix favorable sur beaucoup de
sujets à transférer la responsabilité
les financements et le pouvoir normatif
mais il a indiqué en outre qu'il fallait
engager un vrai débat en profondeur sur
la répartition des compétences entre
l'État et les collectivités
ce chantier il a promis de l'engager au
premier semestre 2023 alors déjà en 2020
l'AMF région de France et
vous même la DF réunissent sous la
bannière territoire unie plaider pour
une grande loi de décentralisation
vous demandiez une vraie une véritable
loi de décentralisation une très grande
loi de liberté pour plus de liberté
locale pour plus d'efficacité c'est vrai
qu'on sort d'un la loi 3DS a été adoptée
en février 2022
ma question c'est est-ce qu'elle n'avait
pas cet objectif et qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait de plus aujourd'hui si donc si
l'on considère que cette future loi sur
la décentralisation pour qu'elle
devienne une très grande loi de
décentralisation
ça c'était le premier sujet le second
sujet vous avez évoqué les la question
des finances des départements qui
étaient qui étaient en difficulté moi je
voudrais revenir sur vos propos dans
l'interview que vous avez donné à la
Gazette des communes le 13 octobre
dernier vous aviez déclaré faire de
votre ligne rouge alors j'ai compris que
c'était sur les droits de mutation là
c'était sur le sur les contrats de
Cahors tout en déclarant être prêt à une
participation tous les départements à la
trajectoire en volume et non en valeur
avec une réduction de nos dépenses de
0,5% par rapport au niveau d'inflation
au regard des difficultés que vous avez
vous avez souligné dans nos
collectivités je sais que vous l'ignorez
pas avec les Aigles que vous avez donné
j'ai le sentiment que cette approche
semble peu au prise avec les réalités
territoriales que nous que nous remonte
les élus dans les territoires respectifs
et que vous avez très justement pointé
votre déclarations je pense singulière
vous place à ce titre le seul président
d'association d'élus acceptant ce
dispositif et pensez-vous que cette
position principale soit en adéquation
avec l'autonomie financière vous appelez
pourtant de vos vœux dans cette même
interview merci
merci
madame la Présidente moi c'était une
question effectivement sur le devenir
des départements et surtout quel finance
demain pour les départements on a eu il
y a quelques semaines en commission des
finances du Sénat une communication de
la Cour des comptes sur les financement
des collectivités territoriales avec des
scénarios d'évolution j'en ai retenu
deux idées fortes qui me séduisent je
vous cache pas et donc je voulais un peu
avoir votre avis la première c'est dire
que il faut simplifier l'impôt local
avec un pouvoir de taux à un seul niveau
de collectivité et en supprimant surtout
les multiples affectations en clair ça
veut dire l'impôt local
là pour résidentiel c'est pour la
commune et la deuxième idée forte
c'était simplifié aussi le partage de la
fiscalité nationale avec une fraction
unique par impôts et par niveau de
collectivité en clair pour les pour les
régions pour économique et pour les
départements serait sûrement une part de
TVA et de et d'impôts sur le sur le
revenu donc je voulais savoir vous quel
est votre votre réflexion par rapport à
ses propositions de la Cour des comptes
et puis enfin revenir sur les DMTO
effectivement elle a un inconvénient
cette recette c'est qu'elle est très
volatile voilà donc ce serait dangereux
que les on considère pour les
départements que c'est une recette
intouchable quand on a des hautes et ce
qu'il faudrait pas aussi revoir
peut-être le le versement de ces
l'affectation de cette DMTO autrement
quoi que que qu'actuellement je sais pas
voilà peut-être affecté aux communes
voilà qui qui libérerait voilà et et qui
donnerait au département la possibilité
d'avoir d'autres d'autres dotations
merci
président donc soit on pose toutes les
questions que vous y répondez ce qui
peut être bien Pascal
merci madame le Président Monsieur le
Président cher François moi je me
réjouis de cet échange de ce matin qui
permet de rappeler mais les collègues
sénateurs de savent très bien que
le Conseil départemental est la
solidarité de proximité celle des
solidarités sociales des territoriales
ça a été extrêmement bien rappelé il y a
quelques instants moi j'avais deux
remarques ou de questions la première
sur sur la gestion les exemples que
président sauvadaient a évoqué tout à
l'heure qui pour certaines certains
d'entre eux manqués cruellement de bon
sens moi je voudrais savoir s'il y a
aujourd'hui une évaluation de de cette
compétence transport qui a jusqu'à leur
marché bien qui était de la compétence
des conseils départementaux qui a été
transféré
transport scolaire pardon oui
scolaire qui a été transféré à la région
à l'exception du transport scolaire des
jeunes en situation de handicap qui
restent de la compétence des conseils
départementaux et quand j'exerçais ces
belles fonctions de présidente
département j'ai eu l'exemple de
plusieurs familles qui se retrouvaient
dans une situation où il y avait
plusieurs enfants dont certains
dépendaient de la région et d'autres du
département donc c'était devenu
inextricable donc qu'est-ce qu'il y a
aujourd'hui une évaluation de se
transfert de cette compétence qui manque
à mes yeux cruellement de bon sens et
puis la deuxième chose la présidente en
a parlé un sujet qui m'est également
cher c'est celui du 10 faut-il le
rappeler c'est certain établissement
public dans mais dans la présidence du
conseil d'administration et de droit
présidé par le président du conseil
départemental et on se retrouve dans une
situation
ubues où cet établissement public et
quasiment le seul placé sous une double
autorité celle du président pour tout ce
qui concerne la gestion administrative
et financière et puis pour la gestion
opérationnelle le représentant de l'État
à savoir le préfet mais on sait
aujourd'hui que le financement des 10
est exclusivement porté par les Conseils
départementaux d'une part et par les
communes et les intercommunalités
d'autre part c'est pas les 150 millions
d'euros qui vont alimenter les 10 en
investissement qui suffiront 150
millions divisés par 100 sans
département j'arrondis fait 15 millions
quand on connaît le prix des matériels
incendies c'est carrément une misère que
ce qui est proposé donc est-ce qu'il ne
faudra pas un jour poser réellement la
question du statut juridique des 10 pour
qu'enfin il y ait une seule autorité qui
gère l'ensemble de cette compétence
merci
Dieu le président qu'on va faire une
pause parce que on a encore grand nombre
de questions donc si Céline tu sois
Céline tu te raccroches à ce trio soit
tu fais le trio
elle est formidable donc je vais abuser
de mon autorité donc faisons réponse à
ces trois questions si vous le permettez
enfin assez trois questionsneurs et nous
avons ensuite à nouveau trois demandes
d'intervention monsieur le président
donc je fais l'effort mais je sais que
c'est un effort il va falloir maintenant
mesurer concrètement donc vous voyez le
problème de méthode problème de ces
ciseaux moi je suis d'accord avec votre
analyse madame le Président de Gatel
quand vous dites qu'il faudrait
transférer
mesh etc donner un peu de sens le
problème qu'on a aujourd'hui les
départements n'en veulent pas pourquoi
c'est pas parce que c'est pas bien pour
la France c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les moyens ils n'ont pas l'assurance
d'une étude d'impact et des conditions
du transfert aujourd'hui on a déjà
beaucoup de difficultés pour des
médecins recrutés des médecins de PMI la
situation scolaire vous l'avez dit elle
est indigente vraiment franchement et
donc évidemment qu'il faudrait redonner
de la cohérence mais ce que je souhaite
c'est qu'il y ait une vraie mission
avec une étude d'impact une clause de
revoyure et ensuite qu'on se fixe un cap
atteignable on peut là aussi innover
vous savez on a des infirmières en
pratique avancée par exemple nous tous
mes enfants sont vus dans mon
département mes enfants enfin les
enfants pardon du département sont vus
par nos services de PMI
sont vus aussi par des infirmières à
pratiques avancées et en Chine décède
une difficulté c'est le médecin qui
intervient on essaie d'optimiser pour
avoir une réponse maximalisée en fait
généralisée tous les enfants sont vus
avant 4/5 ans ensuite on les perd ses
enfants là on ne les retrouve que
lorsqu'ils sont en situation détériorées
ou confié par le juge ou par décision
administratifs et puis on les après on
les retrouve on les retrouve à 25 ans
donc bon maintenant il y a eu
l'évolution pour les 18 21 ans etc enfin
bon j'y reviens pas mais vous voyez le
on les retrouve après RSA donc il y a
des trous dans la raquette il faudrait
qu'on ait une cohérence pour qu'on
puisse suivre les publics tout
simplement bon mais maintenant dans le
contexte actuel vous savez les
départements ne sont pas pro à reprendre
des des charges dont il serait pas dont
il ne serait pas vérifié qu'elle serait
supportable et compensée surtout que
d'expérience on ne transfère les
difficultés et on ne traçait pas les
moyens qui vont avec sur le
difficultés vous le disiez aussi sur la
loi sur l'application de la loi
effectivement sur l'aspect conventionnel
lycée collège on voit qu'on est face à
des difficultés mais c'est aussi
simplement l'application de l'esprit de
la loi
aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des gestionnaires
on a un guide je vous dire il y a pas
d'empressement à mettre en place le
guide donc pour pour qu'on puisse avoir
un pouvoir d'autorité sur les
gestionnaires moi je vais le faire dans
mon département j'irai jusqu'au bout de
la démarche et d'ailleurs si vous le
voulez mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
je vous rendrai compte des conditions
dans lequel l'application de la loi se
fait dès lors que l'administration est
en comment t'en ajuster les contours à
sa convenance
pour faire simple bon et pour terminer
vous disiez sur le sur le sur le
financement je crois que ça rejoint la
question de Pascal Martin madame la
Présidente sur le financement des 10 je
crois d'abord qu'il faut consommer à
niveau l'idée c'est que chaque habitant
contribue à doute proportion à la tireur
de sa commune à l'effort à l'effort
contributive des collectivités moi je
vous prends l'exemple Dijon paye à la
moitié de la population de mon
département je mets 21 millions Dijon
mais 8 millions parce que sont il y a eu
un décrochage avec l'effort qui était
que les départements font tout effort
supplémentaire pris en charge par les
départements orinflation donc voilà ce
qui fait que vous avez un décrochage et
donc la population égale dans un même
département vous avez vous avez un
décrochage donc il faudrait qu'on puisse
déjà sauver trop clair là-dessus entre
collectivités et ensuite vous avez
raison cette compétence d'État la
sécurité et donc il le aussi il faut que
parce que on va avoir un décrochage en
matière de sécurité civile on va avoir
de nouvelles fractures en matière de
sécurité civile
ça existe déjà et moi je le vois poindre
j'ai assisté d'ailleurs lors du congrès
des affiliation nationale des
apports-pompiers sur le fait que nous
devons tout faire dans notre pays et il
appartient à l'État du veiller à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de nouvelles fractures
dans la prise en compte de la sécurité
civile dans dans selon le département
qui auront les moyens ou non de faire
face voilà pour pour le bon Thierry
bonne question
c'est quoi une vraie décentralisation
c'est d'abord nous permettre d'accomplir
nos compétences dans de bonnes
conditions moi je demande pas j'ai
entendu oui c'est vrai que moi aussi
j'ai fait des déclarations sur il faut
une vraie décentralisation c'est quoi
une vraie décentralisation faut qu'on se
pète aussi d'accord entre nous régions
départements
intercommunalités je crois qu'il faut
qu'on se parle franchement moi je suis
pour territoire unie pourquoi parce que
territoire d'union se retrouve sur
l'essentiel on se retrouve pour dire
ensemble que les il faut des libertés
locales pour agir mieux pour les
Français parce qu'on agit mieux en
proximité que on a vu au plan national
et que c'est le plan national l'État qui
doit nous assurer la capacité à répondre
aux problématiques des Français et on
traitera pas les problèmes de
Seine-Saint-Denis comme les problèmes de
la crèche pourtant ce sont les mêmes
difficultés à vivre pour les gens mais
avec des conditions différentes
d'environnement c'est ça et l'État doit
garantir cette équité cette équilibre
territoriale s'est équité territoriale
par la C'est ça la vraie
décentralisation or ça n'est pas fait
donc moi je pense qu'il faut réfléchir
bloc de compétences par bloc de
compétences redonner de la cohérence et
ça rejoint la question de Pascal Martin
c'est le sénateur quand on parle des
transports scolaires mais enfin
franchement dans quel système
sommes-nous on veut garantir la présence
de nos collèges pour garantir la
présence de nos collèges qui se joue
parfois à quelques élèves vous le savez
nous assurons la sectorisation on tape à
la porte de la région faut nous assurer
du transport scolaire on n'a pas la
capacité à mettre en place le transport
scolaire de la région du 10 ça me coûte
trop cher je fais pas qu'est-ce qu'on
fait
du coup incompréhension totale de nos
compatriotes qui me dit mais je sais pas
qui est responsable
j'emploie pas le mot parce que j'ai trop
de respect pour la représentation
parlementaire pour employer le mot qu'on
nous dit en nous disant débrouillez-vous
entre vous pas le savoir nous et donc
voilà on est dans des situations
incompréhensibles en même temps on a le
transport du handicap et en même temps
pourrait voir parce que le handicap
c'est du transport qui peut être décalé
on pourrait donner de la cohérence dans
les déplacements pour que la personne
perd du transport scolaire travaillant
jusqu'à midi 13h puis après un autre
reprend le relais pour avoir des postes
constitués pas possible
est-ce qu'on reste dans cette situation
alors les régions ne disent toujours pas
mes transports très bien touche pas à
mes transports d'ailleurs on est dans
une incompréhension du peuple et après
on s'étonne de la colère qui s'exprime
dans les urnes parce que de la
compréhension la plus totale au
quotidien dans leur vie voilà ce qu'il
faut qu'on simplifie ensuite les
contrats de chaos moi j'étais au style
du contrat au contrat de car je vous
l'ai dit je ne les ai pas signé
j'observais que certains étaient
hostiles les avaient signés c'est la
liberté locale comme je la prône de
manière permanente je ne ferai aucun
commentaire si ce n'est celui que je me
réserve à moi-même donc contrat après ça
nous sommes moi je suis un responsable
politique
comme vous
la situation dans notre pays elle est
gravissime qui en est responsable il
faut arrêter les dépenses encore
j'entends des chèques distribués etc bon
c'est la décision du gouvernement mais
enfin franchement à un moment donné stop
quand même fois ben il va falloir
regarder les conséquences et les effets
de tout ça simplement ce que je dis
c'est que l'ensemble de notre pays peut
être confronté à d'énormes difficultés
si on a très pas des signaux pour
assurer les marchés financiers vous le
savez je le sais donc je sais que les
collectivités territoriales ne sont pas
responsables de cette dégradation de la
finance publique et je renvoie chacun
ses responsabilités je m'arrêterai là
mais cela dit en responsabilité si on me
dit voilà il faut adresser un signal
aussi que nous allons maîtriser la
dépense publique comme responsable
politique oui je dis qu'il faut
maîtriser la dépense publique parce
qu'on pourra pas tenir dans la durée
avec un à continuer à dépenser plus
dépenser dépenser des pensées donc c'est
à la fois langage de responsabilité
comment est-ce qu'on le bâtit
on le bâtit comme le Sénat a proposé
pas simplement moi j'aurais je serai pas
allé jusqu'à un effort équivalent un
effort proportionné
c'est à dire que l'effort demander à
l'ensemble des collectivités comme
témoignage au peuple qu'il souffre mais
que nous aussi on en a conscience qu'on
veut pas augmenter la dépense publique
mais qu'on veut la orienter en leur
direction pour plus d'efficacité chaque
question de fond
donc moi j'ai dit oui pour la
trajectoire oui parce que je veux pas la
situation allemande ou on s'est retrouvé
en Allemagne avec des difficultés pour
avoir accès à des financements pour sur
les marchés financiers c'est pas
simplement Bruxelles ceci marché
financier donc je dis moi je prends
discuter mais attention on va en
discuter sérieusement ne nous demandez
pas de mettre le pied sur l'accélérateur
de la dépense pour faire face aux
difficultés des Français et en même
temps de mettre le pied sur le frein de
la dépense en nous la contageant j'ai
demandé plusieurs choses d'ailleurs je
j'espère compter sur votre appui
première chose toutes les dépenses non
pilotables dont nous ne mesurons dans
une somme comptables ni de leur montant
ni de leur volume c'est-à-dire toutes
les ises doivent être sortis du jeu ce
sera incompréhensible qu'on nous demande
un effort sur des ises ou une fixons pas
le montant les allocations individuelles
de solidarité deuxièmement j'ai mis en
garde le gouvernement je souhaite qu'on
aille au-delà je sais pas si dira
tout ce qui est contractualisé les plans
pauvreté les plans que nous faisons en
lien avec un regard croisé ou d'ailleurs
l'état nous appelle aussi sur ses
propres politiques
est-ce qu'on les met est-ce qu'on met
ces sommes contractualisées je parle sur
le champ social je parle pas après sur
d'autres sujets d'infrastructures etc on
y va on y va pas c'est un autre sujet
mais sur les champs sociales est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on impose un comptage
lentement sur le sur le champ social
alors qu'on a un regard croisé vrai
sujet moi je leur ai dit attention au
gouvernement les les départements ne
s'engagera plus de s'engageront plus
dans de la contractualisation à cause
des coûts financiers et puis aussi si
vous les faites rentrer dans les dans
les dans le dans le contrôle des
dépenses
troisième chose à demander qu'on est des
clauses de revoyure c'est discuté avec
le gouvernement qu'on est une cause de
voyeur en 2024 c'est-à-dire qu'on
regarde le niveau d'inflation réelle
autour duquel s'appliquera les 0,5 et
ensuite quand une conception non pas
individualisée du contrat mais qu'on ait
une conception collective du contrat
c'est à dire que la masse des dépenses
du département devra être 0,5 en dessous
de l'inflation c'est l'effort
contributif qui semble qui semble
acceptable en tout cas qui est proposé
par le gouvernement voilà les contrats
donc c'est pas un contrat c'est un
engagement c'est pas la même chose je ne
citerai aucun contrat je vous rassure
parce que pour moi je n'accepte pas la
mise sous tutelle j'ai pas besoin d'un
préfet pour me dire ce qu'il faut que je
fasse je préfère il doit s'assurer de
mon contrôle de l'égalité j'ai la
légitimité du peuple pour aller conduire
les missions et j'ai des comptes à
rendre à lui d'abord et ensuite on
préfère EDF pour pour bien assurer que
le corps préfectoral évoluait mais voilà
une fois sur la contrôle de l'égalité
voilà c'est tout c'est tout ce je lui
demande ou d'évaluation bon voilà donc
je suis au clair là-dessus
mais d'ailleurs c'est le langage qui a
pu aussi le le Parlement le Parlement
notamment le Sénat moi je me suis
retrouvé dans ce que vous pensez alors
bien sûr que c'est pas partagé par tous
les départements de France pas il y a un
débat il y a des bagues qui dit on ne
veut rien on dirait entendre parler bon
très bien mais voilà je pense que une
large majorité sur la ligne que je
dernière chose voilà pour la trajectoire
donc on a cause de voyeur 0,5 sur
l'inflation constat de l'inflation 2024
pas d'année blanche prise en compte de
l'année 2023 enfin bon bref vous
connaissez ça par cœur
simplifier l'impôt local Didier
bon moi j'ai pas la solution aujourd'hui
vous dit franchement je n'ai pas la
solution mais le mouvement qui consiste
à dire
on va vous donner des dotations de
l'État et vous irez discuter avec les
temps permanence de vos budget c'est pas
la liberté d'autonomie dont je rêve pour
nos collectivités on a besoin d'un impôt
avec une possibilité de possibilités de
tôt voilà tant vous savez il y a pas moi
je sais pas donnez-moi une possibilité
de de
variation d'un taux on avait demandé par
exemple l'évolution l'évolution des taux
sur les droits de mutation
on nous l'a toujours refusé
même de 0 là on l'a refusé voilà moi ce
que je pense dans son principe puisque
vous posiez la question de dire Rimbaud
c'est le sénateur dans son principe
qu'il y a pas d'autonomie et de liberté
locale sans
autonomie fiscale sinon vous allez taper
la porte de l'État et vous tient
moi cette histoire de transfert je n'en
peux plus ces transfert alors évidemment
on est en train de discuter etc moi
aujourd'hui on a un problème comment
est-ce qu'on a passé en 2008-2009
monsieur le sénateur la grave crise
financière que nous avons traversé
qu'une chute de moitié des droits de
mutation parce que nous avions des
leviers on avait le levier du foncier
bâti et on s'est dit on va faire face
tous ensemble j'explique à mes
compatriotes ils ont accepté cette
impôts nouveau pour compenser et
continuer d'agir aujourd'hui je fais
quoi là ça baisse je fais quoi bah je
viendrai vous voir vous disant j'irai
voir le préfet je vais lui donner les
clés de du département puis-je dire
voilà je sais pas faire allez-y
du travail je préfère
donc on a plus de marche
donc il faudra qu'on réinvente une
fiscalité dans lequel nous avons un
pouvoir de taux parce qu'en plus cette
idée selon laquelle l'argent vient
d'ailleurs c'est pas une idée saine en
démocratie il faut connecter un impôt
territorial avec une une
logique aussi de retour sur son impôt
qu'on paye localement voilà ça s'appelle
droit et devoirs dans une société et ça
peut être participation etc voilà il
faut le réinventer parce qu'on a passé
notre temps le supprimer qu'il a voulu
les collectivités locales non l'état
l'État central parce que quand on vous
tient par les finances et quand on vous
tient par la par la compétence et ce qui
vous reste on n'a pas vocation je vous
le redis avec des sous-traitants de
l'État en tout cas moi je me suis pas
engagé une action publique pour être un
sous-traitant de l'État
je veux avoir la capacité innover et on
l'a prouvé voilà pour les transports
scolaires puis je termine là-dessus mais
c'est franchement fou je vous l'ai déjà
dit c'est franchement il faut qu'on
revoit ça enfin surtout que tout cela se
régler en proximité avec les élus locaux
les mères on a une adaptation des des et
puis on essaie de faire en sorte que
selon la réalité territoriale on adapte
notre système de transport sans quoi
vous aurez vous allez avoir des
insatisfactions voilà j'ai été trop long
je je vous prie de m'en excuser madame
la Présidente alors les aesh pareil
c'est le même principe que pour les pour
la médecine scolaire il faut vraiment
qu'on soit au clair là-dessus et qu'on
nous transfère pas des charges on est
bien d'accord je voudrais permettre à
chacun de poser les questions de ce je
sais que les collègues ont d'autres
rendez-vous non mais c'est nous qui
sommes passionnés par le sujet donc trop
long des collègues ont des réunions
doivent partir avec vous-même c'est
sûrement une contrainte donc il y a
trois questionneurs qui sont les rois de
de l'efficacité
Céline
Brulin Olivier Pacaud et Nadine
bellerault qui sont de régions toutes
super mais différentes départements
voilà ils font également chercher line
merci présidente quel regard portez-vous
monsieur le Président sur les
dispositifs gouvernementaux de soutien
aux collectivités en matière énergétique
et est-ce que vous ne pensez pas qu'il
faudrait réfléchir à des mesures d'ordre
structurels puisque cette crise
visiblement risque de durer un petit
moment
autre sujet toujours en matière
énergétique il semblerait que les EHPAD
ne soient pas considérés comme des
établissements prioritaires dans les
plans de délestage qui sont en train
d'être élaborés ce que vous confirmez
cette
hypothèse
une ministre qui nous a récemment quitté
avait remis sur la table
quitter politiquement parlant sentant
évidemment
avait remis sur la table ici même la
possibilité du conseiller territorial
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez et quel
lien y a-t-il à faire entre la situation
d'asphyxie des départements que vous
évoquez et le fait que ce
territorial reviennent sur le devant de
la scène et enfin est-ce que les
départements de France sont en situation
de faire un peu des projections sur la
situation sociale à venir de nos
concitoyens au regard de leur coeur de
métier je dirais de l'action sociale
puisque tout montre que vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs vous-même y compris dans des
gens qui appartiennent au classe moyenne
il peut y avoir des situations sociales
qui se dégradent terriblement et très
rapidement merci
Céline donc Olivier puis
Nadine merci à vous deux merci
présidente monsieur le Président merci
pour votre plaidoyer pour les
départements on est nombreux ici à être
encore ou avoir été moi je suis encore
conseillé départemental j'ai aussi été
conseillé régional jadis d'une petite
région c'était la Picardie j'ai bien
entendu que vous regrettiez certaines
régions à taille humaine bien équilibrée
ma question en fait c'était celle de
Céline sur le conseiller territorial le
conseiller torial territorial pardon il
est parmi en place par une ministre il
était dans le programme du président de
la République bon et alors ma question
c'est le conseil territorial je pense
qu'il peut être utile j'ai entendu
de nombreux points de questionnements
sur les relations avec la région
dans votre exposé
sur quelle base doit-il être élu un
canton une liste les cantons actuels
quel est votre vision
Olivier pour la pertinence et la
concision Nadine
les faits aussi à juste vous je vous
rejoins sur évidemment le transfert de
compétences des transports scolaires
c'est une vraie catastrophe puisque
c'est un éloignement de proximité et
c'est vraiment un gros sujet pour nous
on est beaucoup questionné dessus et il
faudrait revenir sur cette compétence
justement c'est comme se dit c'est
évidemment conseil départementaux sont
imbriqués étroitement liés où en est-on
en fait des carences ambulancières
puisque c'est un vrai sujet aussi l'aide
à la personne et de plus en plus
sollicité les pompiers en font beaucoup
trop beaucoup
ça rejoint aussi nos difficultés dans
nos territoires en termes de santé et
est-ce que vous avez vous en êtes
satisfait puisqu'il y avait une un
rehaussement de l'indemnité et est-ce
que ça correspond à ce que vous
souhaitiez ou est-ce qu'il y a encore
des marges de progression
je suis pour les libertés locales
monsieur le Président et je ne me
concentre pas de le dire voyez-vous
faisons-le
qu'à l'Assemblée finalement parce que
l'assemblée c'était beaucoup plus voilà
non non je plaisante non non
procès-verbal non c'est simplement par
boutade non non franchement d'abord sur
le sur le plan énergétique je crois que
c'est rattrapé pour les pour les pour
les enfin pour les EHPAD c'est rattrapé
sur le plan sur le plan on a demandé
d'ailleurs à ce qu'on soit dans la
perspective de coupure éventuelle
puisque j'ai vu que aujourd'hui de le
gouvernement veut rassurer les Français
mais se prépare tout de même voilà c'est
ça la réalité je crois au fond
je pense que là on va avoir une
discussion nous très rapide avec les
services de l'État tous nos DGS on a
prévu
de regarder les situations particulières
parce qu'il si une telle situation
arrivait il y a des il y a des personnes
qui sont à domicile avec des problèmes
respiratoires etc des situations quand
même très très précises à suivre et à
porter des réponses sur le sur le sur
les sur les sur les problématiques
énergétiques ah franchement c'est que
c'est quand même compliqué ce qu'on nous
a proposé on est en train de d'étudier
tout ça dans le détail bon je crois
qu'il faut qu'on soit accompagné parce
que quand vous avez un tel choc dans un
contexte budgétaire tendu pour certains
départements en particulier je vous l'ai
dit moi quatre et demi-heure et demi 10
millions 11 millions on voyait un peu le
le choc donc évidemment qu'on pourra pas
tenir alors il faut qu'on engage aussi
très très vite les enfin qu'on sache
très très vite comment le gouvernement
veut engager tout ce qui est le de
l'accompagnement pour pour rénover les
logements au plan énergétique etc nos
propres bâtiments comment tout ça va
être mobilisé parce qu'évidemment c'est
une tendance qui va t'appeler à
poursuivre d'une tension sur la sur le
prix des des de l'énergie d'une manière
très générale donc même s'il y aura des
variations en tout cas
euh l'adaptation au changement
climatique plus le prix d'énergie doit
nous conduire à être encore plus
vigoureux il faut qu'on soit
effectivement accompagné ce qui posera
d'ailleurs la question du logement et de
la compétence logement donc j'entends
dire depuis plusieurs fois de chef de
l'État qui d'entend l'avoir transféré
alors c'est ça veut dire quoi transfert
une petite digue du logement
qu'on vérifie tout ça et ses contours
financiers notamment sur le
sur les critères bon je vous ai répondu
c'est extraordinairement compliqué au
point qu'on ne doit faire des un poids
très précis là-dessus vous-même
d'ailleurs vous avez contribué à la
subissement de critères parce que ce qui
était prévu pour les communes visaient
d'exclure la totalité du champ de la du
bouclier énergétique l'ensemble des
départements ce qui n'est pas tenable
mais ça renvoie la discussion que nous
avions moi je souhaite que dans un
premier temps vraiment se préoccupe de
la situation des départements qui sont
le plus en difficulté pour la montée de
leurs dépenses et pour la chute de leurs
ressources donc il y en a une quinzaine
vraiment je souhaite que le gouvernement
on a un dialogue très vite entreprise
d'ailleurs madame la Présidente je vous
proposerai de vous informer des
discussions que nous aurons avec le
gouvernement sur la prise en compte si
vous le souhaitez et voilà pour
continuer de travailler
faudra qu'on mesure aussi il y a une
question qui n'a pas été soulevée les
conséquences du changement de
l'indemnisation chômage sur le sur le
RSA et puis parce qu'on va avoir on va
avoir on a déjà une remontée du RSA je
vous le disais tout à l'heure
ce qui vient contredire les arguments du
gouvernement selon lequel une hausse
était une baisse
je suis assez pratique aux pratiques une
hausse n'est jamais une baisse mieux
aussi sinon ça s'appelle une baisse ou
un statu quo donc le gouvernement essaie
de nous faire tour de passe-passe je
m'en suis d'ailleurs entretenu avec
Bruno Le Maire pour que nous soyons bien
d'accord sur la syntaxe sur les sur le
conseiller territorial bon là chacun son
avis sur le sujet je ne suis pas mandaté
par département de France et par les
départements pour avoir une position là
dessus bon d'une manière très générale
je crois que l'ensemble des départements
ne sont pas pressés de rentrer dans des
discussions sur le conseiller
territorial d'ailleurs écoutez
franchement arrivé dans nos compatriotes
avec une discussion sur les sur le
conseiller territorial devant les
difficultés devant lesquelles nous
sommes placés je pense qu'on peut en
faire l'économie en tout cas c'est ce
que j'exprimé aller à tribune de
départements de France en disant qu'il y
avait d'autres urgences que de revoir le
mode électoral des conseillers vaut
mieux aborder ces sujets pour nous plus
calme selon moi d'expérience je dis ça
ce qui n'excit pas de devoir y réfléchir
enfin en tout cas par canton c'est ce
serait un conseil territorial mon
sentiment un conseil territorial dans
une région à taille humaine c'est-à-dire
en grande région pour qu'elles sont pas
taille humaine mais en fait elles sont
très grandes trop grandes selon moi donc
évidemment c'est atenable vous auriez
des des assemblées si vous les respectez
à la fois la parité le binôme vous aurez
des assemblées pléthoriques à 200 300
300 personnes donc c'est pas tenable
après il y a l'autre question est-ce que
on garde l'échelon et puis on fait
siéger dans les deux on fait si j'ai une
partie des départements pourcentage des
élus du proportion de leur groupe dans
l'échelon supérieur enfin nous sommes
pas un peu compliqué en tout cas nous
nous je n'ai pas mandat pour entrer dans
ce sujet et je n'y rentrerai pas
voilà donc et je pense moi en tant que
élu à titre personnel je pense que c'est
pas le moment d'ouvrir de tel sujet
qu'en tant de préoccupation quand le
peuple est confronté à tant de
difficulté je pense que ce n'est pas le
moment je l'ai dit au gouvernement ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas se préparer
à une
à ces sujets mais franchement ils vont
mieux qu'on regarde ensemble qu'on
consomme que toute notre énergie pour
améliorer les conditions d'action de
chaque niveau d'activité de chaque
niveau de compétence et c'est ça il faut
qu'on donne un socle de capacité à agir
à chaque échelon et la question qui est
fondée qui est posée directement à notre
pays directement tout le monde a
conscience aujourd'hui que les
départements n'en a besoin tout le monde
on ne sait comme on a redécouvert
l'importance des maires quand il y a eu
la crise de la le crise des gilets
jaunes on appelait vous avez pas le
gilet jaune et pas quelqu'un chez vous
ah bah oui on s'est rendu compte que et
moi je me sentais bien ringard parfois
lorsque pendant 30 ans au Parlement 24
ans plus exactement à l'Assemblée je
disais que chaque commune compte parce
que chaque habitant compte et que dans
un grand pays quand on a la chance
d'avoir ce socle républicain s'il faut
là il faut la préserver même si ce sont
des petites communes même s'il y a peu
d'élus mais c'est un engagement
territorial c'est une assurance de
républicaine territoriale et donc
j'avais une cirrhose bien de 343
communes donc vous imaginez une
circonscription électorale de député de
343 communes alors évidemment c'était
bon pour pouvoir pour voir les mères et
j'étais obligé de les je pouvais même
pas passer un jour par ce par an dans
chaque commune donc chaque commune
compte donc ce qu'il faut personne ne
doute les jetons départementales de sa
pertinence pour agir au quotidien on a
370 000 agents qui sont répartis sur
tout le territoire répartis partout
qui sont capacités de distribuer quand
il fallait distribuer des masques quand
il fallait au secours d'une famille on a
des centres routiers on a des services
sociaux qui connaissent les familles
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire des
départements alors je vois bien poindre
l'idée selon laquelle je l'ai entendu
dire parfois par le Président de la
République
l'état finançant le social il va
reprendre en main le social et chaque
fois qu'il y a une crise ou un une
difficulté qui est enregistrée dans une
maison de l'enfance on s'interroge pas
sur pourquoi il y a eu cette difficulté
sur les raisons qui provoquent ce genre
de situation
on ne démonte pas la mécanique de la
responsabilité de chacun je redis ma
confiance à tous nos agents à tous nos
salariés du champ social y compris dans
la protection de l'enfance qui est
devenu qui est devenu extraordinairement
difficile parce que la violence est là
etc bon qu'est-ce qu'on veut est-ce
qu'on veut faire des départements les
sous-traitants de l'État c'est à dire
est-ce que l'État va dire je reprends la
compétence sociale est-ce qu'on pense
que les dates d'antan
la problématique de l'enfance
que nous ne le faisons nous-même
aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on pense
raisonnablement qu'en éloignant les
centres de décision au moment le peuple
a inspire à de la proximité on va mieux
répondre de ça on va faire est-ce qu'on
va mieux répondre en faisant en faisant
de l'État et en laissant l'état faire
des départements le son bras armé et ses
sous-traitants
est-ce que les départements sont les
services des concentrés de l'état non
non
même si nous avons un dialogue constant
avec les services de l'État parce que ce
sont des missions aussi que nous avons
un partage nous pour agir au proximité
en humanité et le gouvernement pour nous
donner les impulsions de ce qu'il
souhaite faire pour le pays en fonction
des engagements présidentiels et
parlementaires deuxième question est-ce
que nous avons vocation à être les
acteurs de décision prise à l'échelon
régional alors que nous sommes acteurs
nous-mêmes sur le terrain ça vaut pour
la politique de l'eau ça vaut pour les
espaces naturels sensibles ça vaut pour
tout cela on sait très bien que ça se
règle de grande proximité
comment est-ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'on
va laisser les schémas régionaux
permanence l'état discuté de chez Marie
Genot dans lesquels nous ne sommes
parfois même pas associés les contrats
de plan je regarde les contrats de
planches je sais pas ce qui se passe
définition des stradettes voilà on a une
consultation il va se mettre et puis
après on a le résultat parce que c'est
bon pour le pays je ne le crois pas
dans une région comme la mienne en
Bourgogne Franche-Comté et ce qui est
une communauté de destins et d'approches
entre la Nièvre et qu'ils avaient du mal
déjà sentir bourguignonne et le
Territoire de Belfort qui regarde vers
Alsace parce que ça constitue une
communauté de destin d'Alsace est
différent Bretagne c'est différent c'est
une région qui ont un périmètre de
France était déjà le de France et pour
nous ce que ça a du sens c'est ça c'est
cette interrogation que j'ai en tout cas
je vous le dis dans l'intérêt du pays
moi aussi j'étais conseiller régional
c'était parlementaire je suis pas là
pour défendre des boutiques mais je veux
défendre l'idée départementale parce que
je trouve que c'est une idée moderne
puis c'est une idée qui correspond à
l'attente on est à l'attente du peuple
c'est une idée aussi culturel on est de
sa commune on est de son département et
puis on est de son pays
et donc cette idée là je pense que c'est
une idée qu'il faut réactiver parce que
c'est l'idée de la proximité c'est
l'idée de la bonne réponse après il faut
évaluer il faut regarder s'assurer que
tout le monde est traité de la même
manière mais j'y crois voilà après
j'entends ceux qui me disent que c'est
des régions voilà très bien le faire
régional est très bien
mais que les régions s'occupent de
l'économie des grandes stratégies
régionales qu'on revienne à l'essence
même de leur constitution et qu'on nous
laisse agir aussi dans des domaines qui
sont des domaines de proximité de la vie
quotidienne
et puis le dernier sujet vraiment
j'attire votre attention sur le sujet
mais vous le savez tous sur le sujet de
l'eau
on est en train d'avoir un système en
France qui va s'apparenter à ce qu'on a
connu dans un certain nombre de grands
pays Australie Californie etc le prix de
l'eau va baisser dans les métropoles
dans les grandes villes il va exploser
dans le territoire rural
aujourd'hui nous avons une structuration
quelques départements simplement jouer
la carte de la mutualisation
l'aube Gironde quelques départements qui
ont qui ont mutualisé leur leurs
production d'eau et qui ont essayé de
faire des interconnexions j'étais dans
l'Allier aussi dans la vieille qui a bon
aujourd'hui le transfert aux communautés
de communes qu'on
va conduire à d'immense difficultés des
communautés de communes qui sont déjà
exemples un territoire rural qui n'a pas
suffisamment mobilisé en son temps les
moyens de renouvellement de réseau avec
des réseaux fuyard enfin dans beaucoup
d'endroits et une échelle de communauté
de communes qui ne permettra pas
d'assurer face à un changement
climatique qui va se traduire par une
baisse du niveau de ressources qui te
permettra pas de régler ce problème donc
je pense que il faudra revoir en matière
de compétence la possibilité pour les
départements qu'ils le souhaitent pour
les départements qu'ils le souhaitent de
pouvoir intervenir dans la production
d'eau potable et aussi directement dans
dans le sujet des interconnexions ce
qu'il avait fait avant peuvent continuer
à le faire ce qui voudrait faire
aujourd'hui ne peuvent plus le faire
aujourd'hui je suis empêché d'agir dans
mon département empêcher d'agir par la
loi
par une vision très stricte trop stricte
de la loi j'ai impossible de mettre de
la production d'eau possible de mettre
par contre on vient me chercher pour
financer il y a un moment donné
j'arrêterai le financement je le dis
tout net si la loi n'évolue pas
j'arrêterai le financement on peut pas
continuer d'être simplement co-financeur
sans avoir une vision d'ensemble à
l'échelle d'un périmètre du bassin
naturellement et du département qui est
une bonne il faudra qu'on parvienne à de
la mutualisation du prix de l'eau entre
entre métropole parce que ce sera on va
arriver à une situation insupportable le
monde rural on va chercher dedans le
mineral avec des contraintes qui sont
légitimes
on le ramène en ville
le prix de l'eau est en train de se
stabiliser voire baisser dans certaines
villes et il entendra exploser la
campagne et parfois même on revend de
l'eau dans son périmètre en périmètre et
ce qui est en train de se passer c'est
qu'on accélère le phénomène de
densification parce que en même temps
pas d'eau pas de développement
donc vous commencez par dire on densifie
la ville donc évidemment on apporte
l'eau suffisante pour la ville on
regarde ce qui reste aussi comme mot
disponible et ensuite on la répartit on
la répartit moi j'ai assisté à une scène
récemment l'entreprise qui est en milieu
en périphérie de métropole qui a quitté
le lieu il était apporté pour
s'installer sur le territoire
métropolitain au motif que là il y avait
de l'eau et qui a été moins cher
le saisissez-vous vous qui êtes au plus
près de nos compatriotes il faut
vraiment saisir dessus
pardonnez-moi monsieur le Président si
vous permettez l'eau est ici extrêmement
inspirante ambulanciers
avec les ARS d'abord sur le volume des
heures
à prendre en compte sur les carences et
puis il y a aussi des services à
améliorer parce que effectivement on a
un enjeu dans le cadre des pressions que
nous avons sur nos bénéfes sur nos
pompiers volontaires etc ça continuera
pas comme ça donc effectivement il faut
qu'on continue d'assurer la sécurité le
transfert etc les pompiers sont là pour
aider la population mais mais on n'aura
pas des pompiers formés durablement pour
jouer le rôle de taxi c'est aussi simple
que ça donc je vous le dis vraiment il
faut qu'on investige d'ailleurs ce sera
intéressant que peut-être madame la
Présidente il y a une initiative qui
soit qui soit prise pour regarder les
Conditions dans lequel la prise en
compte des
de la carence ambulancière se traduit
c'est traduit on a déjà réglé une petite
partie financière avec le on a porté ça
200 euros je crois c'est je crois que
c'était ça le
mais c'est pas suffisant et le volume il
est pas il est pas pris en compte
dis merci monsieur le Président alors à
titre exceptionnel parce qu'il la mérité
une dernière question mais alors
extrêmement courte de Cédric et
peut-être un mot de conclusion parce que
je sais que vous avez une contrainte
monsieur le Président et que vous nous
avez accordé beaucoup de temps je n'ai
pas de contraintes lorsque je suis au
Sénat elle peut absolument noter ça au
compte rendu il faut elles peuvent
toutes se lever je serai disponible
toujours pour laisser la terre et pour
vous Madame la présidente de la
délégation collectivité territoriale
merci Monsieur Bruno
j'espère que vous penserez encore que je
le méritais après ma question
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
de
vos propos sur l'eau ce que c'est un
sujet de préoccupation et et
un sujet sur lequel je vous interrogez
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il serait
envisageable ou souhaitable ou pas du
tout que les départements puissent
prendre la compétence sur la gestion des
milieux aquatiques et de l'eau de
manière générale qui est aujourd'hui
exercé par les agences de l'eau c'est à
dire à la place des agences de l'eau on
a aujourd'hui vous l'avez parlé aussi de
la question de l'autonomie fiscale
aujourd'hui les agents de l'eau sont
financés par une taxe
et ensuite c'est elle qui met en place
leur propre politique publique sans
forcément le contrôle démocratique que
pourrait qui pourrait exister dans un
département ou dans une région si on
devait le transférer ne vous
semblerait-il pas pertinent que cette
taxe sur sur l'eau puisse revenir au
département ce qui serait un élément
supplémentaire d'autonomie fiscale et
quand ensuite ce soit les départements
en fonction de leur particularisme qui
puisse mettre en place dans un cadre
national évidemment dans une logique de
bassin aussi probablement mais puisse
mettre en place ensuite une politique de
l'eau de l'assainissement et
éventuellement des protections des
milieux aquatiques qui est déjà un petit
peu aussi votre compétence est-ce que ça
vous semblerait une idée pertinente ou
pas on voit en fonction des territoires
des agences de l'eau qui ont des
politiques qui leur sont propres qui
sont pas toujours dans le sens de ce que
le législateur a souhaité on sait pas
vraiment s'ils ont une tutelle le
ministériel ou s'ils sont complètement
indépendants et en tous les cas il y a
pas forcément de contrôle démocratique
est-ce que ça vous semblerait une idée à
creuser ou pas alors pardon je vous en
prie merci
monsieur sénatorial bon je crois que
d'abord sur ce constat il faut vraiment
qu'on ouvre le jeu et qu'on puisse
permettre département qu'il le
souhaitent déjà dans un premier temps
pour intervenir dans le domaine de l'eau
en lien et en lien avec l'accord des
syndicats parce que là on est dans des
situations de blocage
réelles et avec des différentes
territoriales que que les départements
sont en mesure d'apaiser de rassembler
aussi par l'investissement que nous ont
dans le domaine de l'eau sur la question
précise du fonctionnement des comités de
bassinge en vélo moi j'ai présidé le
comité de bassin c'est de Normandie donc
pendant des années qui comprend Paris et
de France dans son comité jusqu'au
source de la scène bon
Normandie etc bon
la gouvernance des comités de bassin
doit être revue
nous sommes sous tutelle de l'État avec
des injonctions parfois qui étaient
incompréhensibles y compris par les élus
et tous les corps qui participent à la
définition de ces politiques à l'échelle
d'un bassin je crois que c'est utile
d'avoir dans un même dans un même dans
une même assemblée les écologistes
parfois les plus voilà engagés les
agriculteurs les industriels parce que
ça permet de dégager des consensus et
c'est important de dégager des consensus
et de tout le monde autour de la table
il y a pas beaucoup d'assemblées on met
tout le monde autour de la table et là
il y a tous les acteurs de l'eau donc
faut-il aller alors le problème c'est
l'injonction du gouvernement regardez on
a tous travaillé sur les sur
l'assainissement de nos collectif vous
en souvenez en disant voilà et puis d'un
seul coup injonction de l'étang finance
plus on n'est plus l'assainissement de
nos collectif enfin vous imaginez les
personnes qui sont là si ce n'est que
lorsque la vente de la propriété on a
l'obligation de se mettre au nord enfin
franchement quand on est dans des têtes
dans des têtes de bassin ou à des
niveaux de failles karstique évidemment
qu'il faut d'aide l'assainissement de
nos collectifs de la personne qui veut
remettre aux normes son installation on
l'a supprimé décision du gouvernement je
n'ai obtenu de la part du gouvernement
faut dire la complexité que
l'autorisation pour l'Agence de l'Eau de
pouvoir intervenir sur les zones de
revêtitisation rurales que sur les zones
de rheur alors vous imaginez à
comprendre le voisin qui est à la porte
d'à côté qui est la Z derrière
etc donc un vrai sujet de fond sur les
injonctions du gouvernement il faut
redonner de l'autonomie de la décision
avec un plan cadrage général mais de
l'autonomie de la décision pour
l'adaptation à la réalité territoriale
dans chaque bassin c'est martial Sadier
qui préside de Rhône méditerranécorce
c'est que d'ailleurs je lui avais
proposé de prendre ensuite la présidence
de commita terbassa bon d'une discussion
entre tous les bassins
faut-il transférer carrément au
département je ne le pense pas parce
qu'une solidarité qui s'exprime à
travers la contribution de chacun vous
sortez l'Île-de-France du périmètre de
l'agence de bassin Normandie je serai
pas spontané à vous à vous suivre
faut-il par contre qui est une
proportion qui soit donnée au
département pas simplement sous terme de
subventions mais un accès à une partie
de la taxe plafonnée dans son ensemble
pour permettre au département d'agir là
oui vous avez une excellente idée à
laquelle je dois vous dire je n'ai pas
pensé spontanément
quand vous me dites cadeau j'adire que
vous faites un cadeau à vous-même pour
Noël c'est à dire vous êtes acheté
vous-même le cadeau parce que matin il
vous appartient à vous législateur de
faire évoluer la loi et moi je compte
sur vous en tout cas pour qu'un
amendement rapide soit passé simplement
sur un point madame la Présidente mais
je compte vraiment sur les sénateurs
pour lancer ce sujet sur un point
simplement c'est permettre à des
départements qui sont propriétaires
d'une ressource potable enfin
potabilisable prends du potable de
pouvoir la mettre en production en
production d'accord qu'on ne rentre pas
dans le débat des distributions parce
qu'on va pas s'en sortir mais qu'on
puisse simplement investir sur un lieu
dont nous sommes pour faire de la
production d'eau potable à l'heure
actuelle je vous le répète nous ne
pouvons produire que de l'eau brute et
pas de l'eau potable et quand vous
n'avez pas le syndicat à taille
suffisante à proximité alors on nous dit
créer un petit syndicat mixte tout vert
bon très bien on crée une structure mais
ça nous renvoie la CDCI et comme la CDCI
a dit pas pas pas de pas de création
nouvelle en attendant le transfert sur
les sur les sur les sur les sur les
communautés de communes vous vous
retrouvez dans une impasse totale est-ce
que je dois aller avec 300 maires devant
la préfecture pour dire faites quelque
chose parce qu'on n'en peux plus on a
besoin d'eau je peux pas en produire
[Musique]
si monsieur le Président cet échange
approfondie sur ce sujet et à Cédric de
cette question parce que ce sujet est
une obsession au Sénat
depuis
donc quand on est obsédé longtemps par
quelque chose certains pensent qu'on
pourrait souffrir d'une maladie
quelconque qui deviendrait chronique au
Sénat non pas du tout c'est à dire que
notre objet qui fait notre objet vous
l'avez dit tout au long de votre
intervention c'est l'efficacité de
l'action publique à partir de la réalité
des choses et en 2016 nous avons voté
ici au Sénat une loi sur l'eau et
l'assainissement disons qu'il y avait un
transfert facultatif aux intercos
puisque jamais dans ce pays enfin
peut-être là cet après-midi mais l'eau
n'a coulé selon un parcours
administratif l'eau elle coule en
fonction de bassin versant donc si la
loi peut permettre d'avoir l'efficacité
qui vise la chose dont on parle c'est un
peu mieux donc nous nous n'avons cessé
de travailler là-dessus le gouvernement
a bien compris que le truc était
compliqué mais il voulait pas changer la
vie parce que il y a une pression forte
du ministère de l'Environnement qui est
une vision très simple qui est la
commune est beaucoup trop petite pour
faire ça donc on va mettre ça
à l'échelle où tout où existent tous les
remèdes donc c'est l'intercommet ça 0
sens et donc on a fini par obtenir une
chose qui est inexplicable auprès des
élus locaux c'est la sub délégation donc
pour faire ça pour dire Homer qui sont
tous extrêmement rapides dans la
compréhension des choses alors vous avez
incompétence ok mais là vous allez la
transférer et ils vont vous la subler
alors moi quand j'explique ça aux mains
il me dit mais sincèrement ses loisiveté
qui vous conduit à inventer des choses
de donc là il y a à nouveau non mais
c'est vrai et le truc il a été encore
démonté à l'Assemblée dans 3ds on a pas
gagné alors Jean Castex il nous a lâché
des petits trucs mais il reste en France
en métropole des endroits où ça marche
pas du tout et donc il y a eu une
nouvelle proposition noire qui a été
déposée ici par le roi de l'eau et de
l'assainissement qui est Matthieu
Larnaud
bien appuyé par ses collègues à juste
titre et qu'aujourd'hui il faudrait que
cette PPL elle soit portée à l'Assemblée
nationale et que moi je trouve que
l'échange que nous avons un peu
approfondie sur ce sujet et très
intéressant et je suis sûr que
Cédric qui vous a posé la question sera
un avocat extrêmement
utile des choses et que derrière ce que
vous dites il y a la question que Cédric
a posé il y a l'agenceification alors
l'agenceification elle peut être très
bonne on n'est pas à caricatural mais
très sincèrement comme nous avons
auditionné l'ADEME comme nous
auditionnons l'Agence de l'eau nous
avons à un moment dépend entier de
politique de l'État
beaucoup à l'eau et maintenant et au
budget de l'eau et donc il y a une
dérive là qui est inquiétante et on est
sorti du principe de l'eau doit aller à
l'eau sans l'eau pas de biodiversité
donc l'enjeu aujourd'hui ce sera
d'amener de l'eau dans tout dans toute
la France on va voir le dans mon
département j'ai des communes qui se
retrouvent sans eau en été quand on voit
les perspectives on va perdre 30% de
notre ressource en eau dans le dans les
15 ans qui viennent quelles conséquences
vous imaginez sur la ressource avec des
problèmes sur les failles carriques où
vous retrouvez plus d'eau là vous en
aviez alors bon le réflexe de dire
touche pas mon dos d'un certain nombre
de communes mais quel est le bon échelon
sur lequel on peut on peut en travailler
alors il y a peut-être il faut qu'on
travaille sur l'adaptation territoriale
de la réponse au changement climatique
et à son précisément adaptation à ce
changement climatique donc il faut qu'on
donne de la souplesse j'ai entendu le
président du Sénat dire qu'il faudrait
qu'on ait des compétences je crois qu'il
avait employé optionnel à l'Association
des maires de France je crois qu'il
faudrait travailler sur ce sujet là en
accord avec des niveaux si par exemple
ils veulent me suivre déléguer la
compétence au département et ben moi je
suis prêt à travailler sur ce sujet là
mais en tout cas il faut vraiment qu'on
trouve le bon échelon et là aussi la
grande région pourrait être impliquée
sur ces sujets notamment sur les
diversité mais il y a une tête diversité
de situation dans une grande région au
regard de l'eau regardez dans votre
région quand vous partez de depuis
Auvergne etc vous redescendez dans la
montagne vous allez vous avez que vous
allez jusque dans le
oui c'est c'est pardon jusque dans
l'Allier etc vous avez quand même une
situation différente et moi j'ai
beaucoup apprécié le modèle de l'Allier
ou l'Allier ils ont créé un syndicat
mais avant les lois de notre aimable Tam
dans lequel figure le département et qui
assure de la de la production d'eau et
de l'interconnexion de l'eau
à l'échelle d'un département et ça
marche et donc ils ont ils font jouer la
solidarité du coup entre ville et
campagnes c'est-à-dire tout le monde
participe de la production de l'eau
sinon le modèle je vous dis va être va
être très inquiétant vous allez avoir de
l'eau ou les contraintes seront
supportées par le monde rural
et le pouvoir de l'eau il faudra il ne
faut pas ignorer le pouvoir de l'eau
derrière dans l'aménagement du
territoire et dans le développement
territorial le pouvoir de l'eau donc ça
c'est un enjeu majeur auquel je voulais
vous rendre attentif mais je sais que
vous l'êtes
nous essayons merci en tout cas monsieur
le Président vraiment merci de cet
échange qui nourrit notre réflexion et
notre action et au sein de la délégation
c'est important parce que nous sommes
tous issus au-delà du fait que nous
sommes de territoire différents mais ça
c'est inhérent au Sénat nous sommes ici
de commissions différentes
vous voyez il y a des gens des
commissions des affaires sociales
culture
économie finance loi voilà et que il est
très important que les sujets ne soient
pas seulement des sujets de spécialistes
mais que l'on puisse partager au Sénat
cette culture parce que les
collectivités elles sont ces
multicompétences soyez assurés de
l'attention que nous portons
à la contribution importante que vous
avez pour cette société parce que je
crois aujourd'hui quelqu'un tout à
l'heure embrouiller le mot de rentable
vous vous rappelez on a un peu réagi là
dessus sur des choses qui seraient
rentables et d'autres qui ne seraient
pas moi je pense que vous êtes au cœur
et je le dis très simplement de l'avenir
et de la cohésion sociale parce que
aujourd'hui je parle pas des désordres
écologiques c'est du nom de nature
ceci dit une font que renforcer la
détresse des gens et la difficulté je
pense que dans ce pays on a un enjeu de
cohésion sociale de solidarité et
d'éducation et d'émancipation des jeunes
quand vous rappeliez les situations
extrêmement difficiles psychiatriques
d'enfants qui se retrouvent dans des
situations
extrêmement difficiles qui vont
perturber leur vie
que ceci génère des dégâts par ailleurs
que nous avons aujourd'hui des familles
qui peuvent être en détresse des
familles monoparentales ce qui fragilise
aussi l'économie enfin on voit bien
aujourd'hui la violence que l'on
retrouve dès l'enfance dans des
proportions très fortes donc je crois
que notre société est notre état et nous
nous devons investir
dans la solidarité nous devons investir
particulièrement dans l'enfance puisque
c'est de la prévention que nous faisons
et prendre soin en amont c'est aussi
d'une manière très simple autant de
dépenses que nous n'aurons pas subir
pour essayer de guérir ce que nous
n'arriverons pas à faire donc merci
merci voilà et comptez sur nous alors
nous ne faisons pas des miracles mais
nous y croyons quand même merci en tout
cas monsieur le Président et merci à
vous tous du dialogue
constant que nous avons avec vous et de
votre disponibilité à tous Comme nous
vous sollicitons et c'est très souvent
merci mille fois